Hello. Welcome back to Rawkode Live. I'm your
host, Rawkode.
This is our clustered KubeCon special part two.
Today, we have three clusters all broken by
people joining us on this call. We are
gonna work in teams to fix them as
quickly as we can.
Before we begin, I just wanna encourage you
all to subscribe to the YouTube channel and
click the bell. This will get you notifications
for all future episodes.
If you're not watching live or even if
you are, but you wanna chat about cool
you wanna chat about cloud native,
or anything in between, come and join the
Discord. There's a few hundred of us on
there now having a bit of fun. And
lastly, thank you to Equinix Medal, my employer.
They allow me to do this on their
time, and feel free to check out the
platform by using the code Rawkode.
Alright. Let's get started. Today, I am joined
by Thomas and Chris. Hello, Thomas and Chris.
Hey.
Alright.
So let's start with you, Thomas. Do wanna
just say hello? Let us know quickly who
you are and then we'll move on and
get started for today.
Sure. I'm Thomas Stromberg.
Once upon a time, I was a mini
cube maintainer. I work at Equinix metal now
working on Tinker Bell. So
looking forward to this. Feeling a little rusty
in Kubernetes debugging, but I think we're gonna
have a time.
It's alright. Nice. The breaks are always really
simple. You want me to know much. I
promise.
Chris?
Hi. My name is Chris Nova.
I am just a computer person who does
computer things
and I'm here
to play with Kubernetes with some new friends.
There seems to be a lot of comments
and chat talking about how everyone feels sorry
for Thomas and I and your cluster. And
I believe some people may have watched your
stream this break during the week, so they
probably know what's coming.
But feel Yeah.
Okay.
Well, let's just get started. We are a
little bit late today. We just had some
technical hiccups that we have all resolved. We're
gonna jump on to Chris's cluster first. So
Thomas and I will be putting on this.
Chris, we will ask you for help as
we need. Feel free not to laugh too
loudly, but we will do our best.
Have No. This is gonna be great. We're
gonna have we're gonna have a great time.
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
Alright.
I have my screen shared. We are floating
heads. I am gonna open a connection onto
the control plane node.
I can see that we have a message
of the day. Thank you for that. Always
appreciate it. Thomas, can you join the session
and give me a echo hello so that
we know we have a shared buffer?
Oh, you're going straight into the node. Oh,
wow. Okay.
Well, I will use the Kubernetes admin token
to try and execute a get nodes or
get pods. We'll see if we have a
working control plane and we'll take it from
there.
I am here. I got coffee. I've got
some kombucha. Let's do this.
Alright.
Thomas, you're muted right now.
I don't
I think Thomas is muted. Yeah. Yeah. You've
muted yourself, man. Sorry about that. Alright.
So I tried to connect in, and it
made my own session. So how do I
share your show? Of course. On the left
hand side, there's some active sessions. If you
can click on that, please. You should see
those one by active sessions.
Okay. I will
join that one.
I'm just gonna get us
oh, I just had that weird screen blip
which means you're in a session.
So I will give you the honors, Thomas.
Feel free to type,
get nodes, get pods, whatever you want, and
let's see if we have a working control
plan.
Alright. Whoo. Okay. Wait. We do. A lot
here for this.
It it in an answers.
So that's one of the more
more impressive things that I've seen here. So
so scrolling up.
I see a lot of NOVAs.
Interesting.
Okay.
So we have a lot
we have a lot of stuff here. So
one of the let's see.
Google.
What's
it's the thing to
no.
It's the thing to dump all the config
to a
file again.
Buster info. That's
what I'm trying to do. Alright.
Okay.
So,
yeah, we got a lot of junk going
on here.
I love watching. I like I've already learned,
like, three things just watching you so far.
Well,
so as I was talking to I I
mentioned this before the the stream that,
know, when I broke a cluster previously, I
realized that one of the things this is
like is it's it's almost like investigating
a security incident. Like, you've got a parasite
in your system.
So I'm I'm trying to collect some information
first.
You're doing great. In in which case, like,
I feel like I I I left a
good amount of clues. So this is gonna
be really fun. I'm stoked to see how
this plays out. So
this is really weird scrolling behavior, though. Alright.
Yeah. Just reload the page. It'll fix the
scrolling behavior.
It it does happen, actually. It's really annoying.
I got it.
Sort of. I haven't. Sorry. I can't see
the bottom of my screen yet.
There we go. Alright.
So what is the
the test to see
the
what do you call it?
Isn't there like a WordPress app or something
that we're supposed to do to see, like,
how it works and
to effectively say, is this thing healthy?
It looks like it's What would rate for
is this healthy?
It's running. I
I I would say if if you can
get
the WordPress app or whatever it is that
that Rawkode has in in his repo, you
can get that running
and and get the cluster into a state
where it'll continue to run. I will I
I will buy you a steak dinner.
Okay.
So we do have a clustered pod running
in the default namespace.
Whether it's actually running or not, I'm not
sure.
Whether we can even upgrade it to the
version two, I'm doubly not sure.
Alright. So
What is FLS?
So one of the things I'm going to
do
is
basically make a
since I know we're dealing with a kernel
hacker here,
I'm going to make a, basically, a dump
of the file system
and
a dump of all the file system changes
recently.
So FLS is part of SleuthKit, which is
showing my age a little bit.
I
I I've I put this on easy mode.
If I would've known we were really gonna
be doing this, I would've it would've made
this a little bit more fun for us.
Alright. So I'm act I'm just collecting information
before mutation here. So
so for instance, what I'm showing oh, this
machine was installed recently.
Yeah. These are cluster API clusters. They respond
off a few days before. So
So I don't know when
alright. I'm just gonna start with
so
for instance, I can see that
the most recent changes on the file system
are
basically here. It's basically sorted order of changes
in the file system, and I'm going to
collect it for later. I do notice
some bizarre things already here. I see a
system d
change here. It looks like some files were
edited in this directory with them.
So
so yeah. Anyways, let's go to the let's
now that I've collected the the data,
how do we get can can you drive
a little bit for how do we test
your WordPress app?
Yes. We can definitely do that. So Alright.
What I would normally do is
run get pods.
And I should have just used my alias,
but there we go.
Well, okay. Our app is
So it's gone. Gone.
Yeah. Okay. And and just just for the
record, I just I I really like the
fact that they're all in crash loop back
off. That that was by design and and
I'm just really happy with this aesthetic right
now. So this was a big part of
my work.
I love that you've got it to deliver
a message all nicely lined up. That's that's
pretty special.
So where do we find your app to
deploy?
Okay. So we can just
press space.
Switch over to a do that locally, but
we can do that.
Alright.
Okay. Clustered.
This is cluster 22,
and I can just run just workloads, and
we'll see if it works.
This is what I love most about this.
This just just
this makes me gives me the warm and
fuzzies.
So we it did create it.
At least it says it did, but
running get pods on teleport
as a big no no,
which makes me think.
I don't know yet.
Are we speaking to the real API server?
Yeah. So I'm gonna run my Just Workload
again. I wanna see if it says changed
or created.
Okay. It's saying created. So we're getting the
API server. We're getting a response, but nothing
is changing state in the cluster.
Alright. So let's take a look. I'm not
I'm not quite following here.
Sorry. So
can you see my screen at the moment?
Yeah. I I can see your your screen,
which is the same as my screen. Yeah.
So on my local terminal, which I I
need to deploy the application, I ran Yep.
Just workload twice. And you can see here
we're getting created and created. So, like,
I don't think it's actually being created. Otherwise,
we'd see unchanged on that second deploy. So
where we are speaking to an API server,
we're not
something's not happening on the back end, so
we need to work that out.
Alright.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It's
somewhat difficult, but not impossible, to have
a fake API server. But what is going
on here? Are we talking to the API
server on the right machine? Yeah. So I
I think we probably are based on the
fact that Chris didn't know we were gonna
jump on to the node and use this
token.
So
I think
Yeah. I mean, the certificates match and everything
else. Like Yeah. So I think this is
a real API server. I'm assuming we've maybe
got
yeah. If it was a, like, an admission
controller, it wouldn't say created on our site.
So it must be someone else.
I can see Chris just giggling.
I'm
I'm I'm not giggling. I mean, to be
fair, like, Thomas Thomas is the hero. Like,
the game's kind of already over.
But, like, I I wanna see how you
would go about fixing this because this is
gonna be really cool. And I think this
demonstrates a lot of
I mean, like, I I'll just let you
guys go through it. You're doing great. You're
gonna you're gonna find it. Alright. I'm I'm
gonna go first with
identifying the weird things that I saw in
the file system. Okay.
And hope that will give us some of
the
some of the interesting bits here.
And so we we have this wonderful bash
script that I saw earlier,
which is highly suspicious here.
It's highly suspicious. And to be honest,
I was I was anticipating this being the
last thing we found. So watching you approach
this the other way is gonna be really
fun. I'm real I'm literally, like, tickled right
now. This is great.
Yeah.
Oops. Okay. So
so what did we do here? All right.
So you did mention
oh, you are evil. Is this an API
server aggregation?
This is
yeah. Look at this.
The affected API server.
So, yeah, you were,
Oh, what did you do to my life?
Oh, okay. I'm sorry.
So
okay. So there's there's a lot of evil
happening here.
Let's see.
What what do we do here? Right. So
okay. Okay. So I see so I'm base
basically just dumping a list of here are
all the images on running containers.
Let me actually do this a little differently.
Thomas, I'm gonna have to get that FLS
command from you. That that that thing saved
the day here. That's the real hero of
the show. If everybody here walks away with
that copy pasta from Thomas, we're
If you if you,
yeah, if you ever have to deal with
infected machines now there's probably better things. This
is what I used, like, fifteen years ago.
But
Yeah. Let's
see.
So
so infect API server. I mean, that seems
to be, like, one of the first things
to kill, I guess. Well, can we check
some of the basics first? Right? Like Yeah.
Yeah. Let's check the basics. Look in the
static manifest,
like, I expect to see an API server
here. Yeah. Immediately, see it's been date is
different. Modified.
Yeah. Okay. There we go. It's with that
with that it's that temp file we saw.
Yeah.
So we could use QBDM just to reprovision
the APIs to our phase. Right?
Yeah. So I wonder now here's here's a
question that FLS can help the FLS data
can help identify.
Was
was the original copied was was Chris
nice enough to copy the original one anywhere
else? I actually, looking at the script, it
doesn't look like she was.
I I I have a copy. I I
have a copy.
Yeah.
I can I can send you one as
well? I just have to go in the
other room and get it off my local
social team.
So, yeah, I think that's
look. Can we kill that
that infect pod and then Well, we can
remove the the API server from the manifest
directory, which the kubelet will then get rid
of it.
We can either copy the q b d
I API server from another machine or we
can try and fluff our way through the
q b d m commands, which I think
is
in a oh, no. Help.
Is it not phases?
Phases.
Hold on. I'm trying to remember how to
curate the end. A phase for just dumping
the config,
I think.
I'm
sure it's in it phases something.
Why did I not remember how to do
this?
So a a clue would be
if you can get just get rid of
the container, that little everything I put in
the comments, that's that's really the only mutation
you should you should care about. It's I
I put a big block around it.
So it should be safe to say if
if we can get that code block to
go away,
we'll we're we're back you know, Jurassic Park
is back online. Well, that pod should already
be deleted because we removed the static manifest.
Okay.
Sorry. What did you say there?
I thought that pod would be away because
we removed the static manifest, but then I
can see in cube system, we still have
a cube API server.
Oh, that's just a real API server.
Can we edit that?
Oh, no. No.
That can't be right.
Yeah.
Hey. Did I not delete this file?
No. We haven't deleted this file yet. I
did.
Oh, did it get reinserted by
A mysterious force? I think so.
Oh, sorry. On you go. Stop.
This is great. I I love watching the
the teamwork here, how we have kernel introspection
coupled with Kubernetes expertise because this is this
is good. This is good stuff.
I I am so sure I did an
RM on that failed to to the move.
I I did not see an RM. Alright.
Let's let's do it again. We've always got
the fact that copy and temporary. Maybe I
just wasn't paying attention. But
yeah.
It's there again. Excellent.
So so
I think it's basically just reinserting itself. Yeah.
Wonderful.
What's the e attribute?
Beats me, but it could just be the
same as others.
Alright.
So we have unknown processes running on this
machine that are that are mutating this file.
So
we could use,
like,
audit CTL or something like that to actually
watch the file system changes. But
then I have a lot of copy pasting
to do, and I don't I don't have
audit CTL memorized. So
but So there's there's,
like, three directions I can nudge us in,
which would be fix
going about Kubernetes
and and what we would wanna look for
there and how we could find some introspection
there. There's the the things on the file
system we've already found. There's some more clues
in there as well. Oh, yeah. And then
ultimately,
I think,
like I said in the beginning, that that
first FLS, that's like, you got the keys
to the kingdom right there, baby. Like, that's
got all you need.
Yep.
Alright. So let's let's go ahead and disable
some of these random things we found in
the file system. And there's there's a I
saw two suspicious system b services,
one NTP and one Nova. So let's let's
go ahead and look at those. So
And I I I did name everything very
politely,
if that makes sense. Yeah.
Alright. So
alright. So
system
so we have this Nova service
that starts that up so we can
and
we've got this NTP service that
was
a little suspicious,
but maybe not
that suspicious.
Looks It's clear. Fairly normal.
Yeah. So that should be fine.
Alright.
So
So we did a system control disable, but
I don't think that stops it. Right?
We'll need to stop it as well. Yeah.
You're right.
Do we think that's responsible for putting the
dodgy manifest back in this directory? Yeah. It
well, it at least has the capability of
putting dodgy manifests in place. Let's see.
There we go.
Well done. Alright. Well done.
So
since we know the calling card anyways, I'm
just gonna look here and see if there
are any suspicious other things. I see there
is in the root directory
also a Nova, but that might have just
been development.
Yeah. There's I mean, there's a couple of,
like What is with this? LibNova? Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'm happy you found the calling card. You've
done this before, haven't you, Thomas?
I've investigated
break ins before.
That's bad.
Not in a long time.
Yeah. No. You're questioning.
Alright. So I
might have broken something. I hope I did.
Go for it. Try to list. That'll let
you know. Just try to list, and you'll
you'll get it real quick if you I
mean, try to do anything on the file
system.
There you go.
Alright.
So we found
I
forgot And so this is where
lds0.preload.
That's the one.
Okay.
You can just echo echo empty to it,
and that should that should fix it. Yeah.
Beautiful.
And list?
Hey. Okay.
K. We got one interesting bizarre thing out.
Okay.
Next
is
alright. So what do we gotta do now
for looking at
Well, we have no API server.
Oh, no. We don't. We have an API
server, but it's not really the right one.
So
I don't know what config you used to
generate like, what the options were for your
Cube ATM
cluster initially
to create a new one.
Okay. I will grab an API server manifest
from one of the other machines.
Alright. And I'm just gonna okay. So
so
what I'm gonna do is just look contextually
if there are any other interesting events in
the changes file around
here.
And I see the well
Alright.
I see the LDSO preload
thing here.
Do mind if I paste in this manifest?
Yeah. Go ahead and fix the manifest.
Yeah.
Thomas, share that that FLS command with me.
Sorry. I your your reputation
preceded you, so I
I knew Yeah. Roughly So this is one
of equals on my encounter.
You did well.
This is one of the things we we
spent it was, like, last night and the
day before, we spent a couple hours, like,
meeting some of the the guys on Twitch.
I say I'll say guys, but folks on
Twitch. And it was, like, do you know,
should we should we name these, like more
conspicuously?
Should we have a common calling card? Like,
how much cleanup should we do? And we
we kind of were like, let's let's keep
it
fun. And I think this is I'm I'm
thoroughly impressed.
This is well done.
Getting the rest of the cluster to clean
up is
not impossible.
It's it's it should be pretty straightforward here
once we start digging around.
My teleport's not typing anymore.
Yeah.
Didn't Dave you David send you the message
that this was supposed to be an easy
one?
No.
Oh, okay. He told me I should make
it an easy one. So
I said because it was time box, we
should take it easy.
Oh, sorry. Well, if if you're interested, I
can I can kind of guide us through
the rest of this really quick? No. No.
No. We're we're Yeah. Let's let's keep let's
keep break.
My Firefox is crashed. Breaking it or breaking
it more. So can you if
your teleper is still working, I think there's
a couple more IP addresses that need changed
in that file.
Yeah.
My teleport session is still working here. Yeah.
I need to
get mine back up.
And really the
a lot a lot of this is prior
art from from other scenarios I've gone through.
And,
you know, if there's there's a lot of
good Easter eggs and good, like, tips and
tricks. So I I was hoping and then
we already got one of them, which is
that that fabulous FLS command. I was really
hoping folks
would would walk away from this knowing that
there is some some things to watch out
for.
And let me grab
this.
But really in the in that that static
manifest now that's not being overwritten with that
errant system d service, you really should just
be able to leave that that one container
and and the clusters. And then it's just
cleaning up the cluster at that point.
Yep.
Okay. So that should be a working, hopefully,
API server. Can we delete the x file?
Yeah. You can delete the x file. That's
fine. Alright. Let's check for
Sorry? Don't like me. Alright.
So
so what are you looking for here? Oh.
I'm just waiting for the API server to
come back. Static. Yeah.
In theory, I should.
Oh. I should.
I'll let you type, Thomas.
That mean we can run get pods and
actually see? Yeah. Let's see.
Alright. So I we could probably just delete
that whole namespace.
Yeah. Let's see.
I'll do this thing.
Old school way, I guess.
The first one's You can do dash dash
all now, Thomas. You can do delete PO
or delete namespace now.
Oh, yeah.
Well
As long as there's no admission controllers on
there in that in space with other objects
with finalizer, it would be fine. Alright. I'm
just gonna do it this way.
Good.
I love I love seeing
somebody really proficient on the command line like
this. This just this just touches me right
in that, like, soft place in my heart
that nobody ever goes.
Alright. So those are terminating.
We still have some of the default ones,
but that's fine. I'm not I'll I'll I'll
leave your calling card there.
I accidentally killed two of them, but whatever.
I'm curious to see if they come back.
Yeah. Me too.
Still terminating. That's not looking good.
They they they should
we'll see. Yeah. They're they're done.
It looks good. Yeah. That in this case
is all cleaned up. Yeah. Cool. Oh, well
done.
Do you wanna try your deploy again and
see
if we have a healthy deploy?
Unchanged. Unchanged. Excited.
Yay.
Good job.
And
they're running.
We got Postgres and clustered. And I guess
the last thing is to verify connectivity.
Well, have to edit deployment clustered.
We should be able to upgrade Why are
you editing?
We're Oh, I was trying create a video.
Okay.
Which I suspect will work fine, and then
we'll port forward and see.
I'm still impatient.
So I have to ask,
since I didn't disassemble
your library or even, you know, really dump
any debug,
what
Slash temp. Go check out slash Go
check out slash temp.
I I figured if if you were looking,
slash temp is like that's I feel like
if if I put it in slash temp,
it's that's the difference between hacking and security
research. It's fleeting things in slash temp.
Exactly. I I I saw there was the
temp nova director. I haven't looked at what
all or the file, but I haven't seen
what else. It's it's I love it. It's
very
Yeah. You should just list everything in temp
and it's a hidden file called dot nova,
I think. It might be obscure. It's caught
in there with last. And
yeah. I left it's very polite in there.
There's even a a lovely make file for
you as well.
Excellent.
So let's Yeah.
I guess before we drop off, I wanna
quickly
browse those files. But
so far, things are looking too good to
be true.
No. You did great. You honestly, I I
mean this sincerely. You knocked it out of
the park. This is this is well done.
Alright.
So let's
let's see. Oh,
damn.
Okay. So there is the dot Novo
file where
What all files were there in temp?
How do how do we get back?
Are you back in temp? I don't I
don't see Yeah. I'm I'm in temp and
the the dot Nova was the
Look for a different file. Just list list
long temp.
Everything in temp.
Okay.
Obscure. I see. Temp obscure.
There you go. And this is I even
think the shared object should be there.
There you go. It is.
Oh, hiding process the process.
Okay. This is this is a very common
I did so we
we thought about doing an eBPF something or
other,
but this is just good old l d
preload, and and that was kind of, the
big talking point I wanted to get here.
And,
yeah, I can see that my p f
that I did earlier, the Nova did not
show up. So
My heart was beating out of my chest
when you did that p s. I can't
even and it and it didn't work. And
I was like, oh, I've got them. I
fucked I fucking got them. And then it
was and then
David was just like, oh, no. You gotta
do a system cuddle stop. And I was
just like, that's gonna get it. You can
know that the PS didn't show it.
Cool. Yeah. No. Well done. This is great.
Thanks. Alright. Well, our port forward didn't work
to browse to the application. Does that mean
there's more to It
should it should I didn't touch the network.
Alright. You're you're welcome.
Alright. Good job, Thomas.
That was a
Thank you. That was nice to watch. FLS
is now gonna be stuck in my brain.
Yeah. So SleuthKit,
it's it's an old technology, but there are
many other things. There's but one of the
nice things about FLS
is that it also notices deleted files because
it is dumping the raw EXT
file system data
and not just relying on the current state.
So
Nice. So check out if you go to
the root directory and look at the bash
RC, I hit a little there's a a
bash forward in there and there's
a I made the assumption a couple of
assumptions with this. One of which was that
if you were looking at the raw block
device logs in any form like with FLS,
you were gonna get everything. But
even if y'all were to exit out of
this and come back, it you it's gonna
clean up after you're on the way out.
Check out dot Nova in here. There's it's
I hid it somewhere in there. I don't
know where the pointer is. Yeah. There you
go. That very last line.
Yeah.
So yeah. I mean, it was superficial clean
clean, but but really looking slightly deeper into
the Linux system, you were gonna get a
lot. And I think this this is good.
Nice.
Excellent.
Thank you for for setting up this scenario.
It was fun. It it Yeah. It exercises
a lot of muscles that haven't been used
in decades.
So
Great.
Alright. And I think the
yeah. Yeah. What do I do? Tell me
what to do. No. If you got something
to say, go for it, and then we'll
jump into Thomas' cluster.
Yeah. I'm trying to figure out how to
open up Thomas' cluster. I'm here in the
teleport browser,
so I just go to root and click
on connect. Is that what I do?
Hold on because I got logged out when
I restarted Firefox. I'm I'll start a session
just so it doesn't flash your IP address
on the screen.
Oh, because if I go to active sessions,
your IP will be there. Let's just then
do Okay. Yeah.
Yeah.
So
I'll open the control plane and if you
go to active sessions now, you should be
able to see that join and then just
type echo hello or anything like that.
Okay. So I see a few seconds ago.
I see two of them. I see Rawkode
options
join.
Oh, because I just have one when I
was copying the API server. So if you
yeah. The one you've just joined is the
correct one. It's my screen flashed.
Let's see.
So I'm gonna have to admit, I I
was not nearly as creative as you.
Okay. No. That's good. That's good. I so
I didn't really know what to expect, and
I I kind of live in a bubble.
Like, I I've I've taken a step aback
from kind of what's going on in cloud
native and Kubernetes and everything. And so, like,
really, all I knew was here's here's a
Kube config and an SSH to a cluster
and break it. Yeah. And I was like,
okay. Well, I've got some some good, you
know, horizontal
attack vector tools, and I just kinda put
together a fun scenario. So
I I I have no idea what to
expect here and I don't know very much
about you, Thomas. So like,
you're gonna get to watch me frail now.
Yeah.
I'll just say everything's working just fine.
Oh, great. Well, I have exported
kube config path and alias kube control to
k. So if you wanna run, get nodes,
get pods or anything else, Chris, and we'll
we'll see where we're at.
Well, I I want it I feel like
I should return the same favor of collecting
before mutating.
But I I don't even know if that's
gonna that's gonna be necessary.
But let's
yeah. Yeah. I'm just gonna just do
just check out the state of the cluster,
I think. We'll start we'll start at the
top work our way down. Whereas I think
we we started at the bottom and worked
our way up the last. So let's just
let's just get let's get pods in the
default namespace, and I'll run the command that
I wanted everyone here to I wanted you
guys to run.
So that looks good.
You both managed to drop a message and
to get pods. That was It's tradition at
this point.
Yeah. Wow. Okay. So, like, now I'm I'm
wondering, should I should I be collecting information
on on the the file system here?
Well, he says he kept it simple. Maybe
maybe we I kept it very simple. I
don't I don't
I'll I'll say there are no root kits
on this machine.
Okay.
Well done. So then let's let's see what
we have here. So let's
let's get
we'll get all in the cube system namespace
and see what we got here. And I'm
just I'm just looking at this point. So
everything looks fine. It's all running. The control
plane looks good.
Yeah. So no crazy restarts. I mean, already
the things I did were sticking out to
me like it's sore thumb. You know, I
had two containers running in the API server,
you know, fourteen, fifteen, 16 restarts.
Let's get namespaces
and let's see.
We have Rawkode. We have metal l b.
These all look fine. Selium looks fine.
And I guess the success criteria here would
be
if I scroll up, we do not have
our application running. So I'll I'll I'll do
the same thing that that that we did
on my cluster. David, could you please deploy
your application and see what happens?
Indeed.
And I have to ask, was the was
the pod honk
Whose idea was this? Where did this come
from?
Okay. Well,
we got a etcd server. This database space
exceeded,
so we can't write to etcd in order
to deploy our application.
So we've seen this before on clustered. Sorry.
Let me go.
Can you oh, can you go back and
and show that? I I missed what you
just said.
So we've got
etcd is complete. We can't write to etcd
to do the deploy, and it's because the
database space has exceeded.
Okay. We'll Let's see.
Just wanna check out our file system here.
So that's okay.
This all looks good superficially.
And I'm gonna I'm gonna trust Thomas here
that there's no rootkits and that nothing. These
are all actual real numbers.
The last time I seen this error on
this show, the problem was either
I think the attributes were changed on the
STD fails, so it couldn't be written to
it and then the other one was someone
modified the STD configuration
which actually has a size attribute.
So which says we can only write this
much to STD and then it stops accepting
anymore.
So I think we'll need to
do that. And I have a cheat sheet
that I always use for entity because I
can never
remember entity.
So
I'll get that set up for us.
I'm also I'm also curious about these these
Honk pods as well.
I don't know anything.
App install
s c d file.
I don't know anything. I love I love
this. Oh, this is evil. I was so
mean to you guys. I'm so sorry.
That's that's okay. I so I've I've broken
one other cluster for clustered,
and I
and I I did get
excessively evil in that one. So I was
encouraged to keep it simple this time.
I see. And
Yeah. We destroyed the boxes so much, we
couldn't go on to fix it.
So I mean, I I was like like,
what what else do we wanna do here?
I do I recompile a kernel and like
put a new kernel image in the bootloader?
Like like, what are we what are we
doing here? And I just was like,
my my promise to myself was we will
we'll stop at the layer right above the
kernel. Like, when I started entertaining the idea
of loading kernel modules or eBPF probes, I
was like, nope, Nova, that's just you can't
be that mean.
Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah, back to fixing that d
d. Let's see what we got here.
Yeah. So at CD, we now have a
working client so we can speak at CD
if we if we need to. It doesn't
look like fails to be modified, but of
course we know that means nothing on Linux.
Yeah. You can I I I Linux timestamps
are adorable?
Yeah.
I think on this part one today, all
three of us modified all the date times
on the static manifest.
They can no longer be I thought I
thought about doing that or like mutating any
of the I node
features and I was just like, no, just
keep it nice.
Keep it real.
Well,
I I I don't see anything
weird
here.
Can
we check out the STD logs?
I just wanna see what what the STD
logs are saying in the control plane.
Oh, there's two of them.
Let's try You can tail star. I like
if if yeah. There we go.
Dialing
connection refused.
That doesn't look right.
What's going on?
202379,
that's the STD
socket we're listening on. Right?
Yep.
So what's what's going on with that? Can
you can you can you hit that socket?
Can we send data? Can you in map
that? What do we got? Who's screwing with
my network? We can because we can run
an STD get.
So we are successfully able to speak STD.
We got some data out.
What what command did you just run at
c d cuddle? Yeah. Get and then pass
in a path and let's just close that
Kubernetes service. Okay. Cool.
Okay.
And it's still saying it's unable to write?
Where did what does that c d write
to?
So
if we take a look at the static
manifest,
we will see that it's written to I
think it's varlib etcd.
There's a host path in here.
Yeah. Varlib etcd. Well
done. Thank you.
And
you can just delete any of the files
in here, and it'll recover just fine. Don't
worry.
That didn't sound sincere.
So these are all 62 meg files.
Okay.
So this is this is effectively the STD
database?
It was yeah. Can can
you type can can you type history? I
just wanna see if what if we have
anything there in the batch history.
Yeah. Let's see what else we got here.
Scroll down. Yeah. This is just our stuff.
Okay. That's clean.
So there is because I only know this
because this happened before, but there's an x
t d max
database size thing that I bet has probably
been
set.
Yeah. I don't know. I my work with
the STD is is really limited.
So I'll I'll at least give give a
hint that might help. Sure. I've actually
I didn't SSH into this machine at all.
Of course, you didn't.
Well, okay. So I SSH in to verify
that I could SSH in, but I didn't
do any mutations over SSH because I wasn't
sure how to SSH in to begin with
anyways.
Me neither. I did everything. I just Over
APIs.
As did I. I just privilege escalated into
one of my hack pods for everything I
did.
Yeah.
Have we lost our API server?
I don't know. Check and see.
Hello? Yeah. That looks fine.
Okay. That's not working.
So I'd I would be willing to say
that
because ETCD is not
responding,
the API server's hanging.
This IP address is
wrong.
Was that a cron job change?
That would have been sneaky.
I'll I'll say there are no cron jobs
on the system.
And no system d services.
I tried to keep it very different this
time.
Did you use system d services last time?
Yep.
Nice.
Alright. So it looks like
So we can't hit local host?
So we were able can you just try
to list we tried to list pods and
it's hanging now. Correct?
Yeah. Unless
I am losing my mind. Bet we we
were able to list pods. We've seen that
Thomas has necessarily all those pods that said
honk.
Obviously, was some sort of timer thing happening.
So maybe it's like Kubernetes job. But
Yeah. There's there's no timers that I implemented.
Just keep in mind that oftentimes the API
server gets really grumpy if etcd is grumpy.
Yeah. That's I I mean, the etc
server in general can take thirty plus sixty
seconds to kind of get to a back
to a happy state sometimes.
Oh, we've lost HTT server
failed to apply request.
No space. It's it's just no space again.
It's gotta be something
somebody
flushed a large amount of data to a
pod somewhere. I'm
those honk pods, if we get rid of
those, they're I would hope that it's something,
like, they're just writing a large amount of
data somewhere to the API server, like, the
form of a label or something.
Okay.
So
we need to be able to shut down
those processes then.
I think getting rid of the honk pods
would be a good first step.
And then I also I also like the
idea of trying to flush etcd as well.
But I don't know how much the persistent
state of the cluster we would nuke if
we just started manually messing with etcd files.
I have I'd again, etcd is like I
just
I haven't really had to debug it Yeah.
In dev. My my recommendation,
do not use the file system. Use use
the Etsy client.
Yeah. That's Unless that's really useful. That means
I have to know how to work the
Etsy command
line application.
Is there an alternative for us?
Do we got a shell? No.
No. Can I can I drive for a
second? Please. Please.
I typed, you know, nothing happened.
There we go. Yeah.
I wanna see this really quick.
And
the connection was refused,
and
let's p s ox
grep cube.
And which container runtime are we using?
Container d.
What's I see all these new fancy container
tools. I don't know what these kids these
days are doing.
Okay. So let's look and see.
I wanna how do we what would be
the docker p s for So we tested
to a cry control
socket.
Okay. I can't remember exactly. This may work.
Yeah. I can tell you've done this before.
But then you have to add PS at
the end. Oh, it's a runtime endpoint. Right?
I remember in a previous episode, showed
off the like, you can just set the
default for setting the runtime endpoint in the
CryCuddle config to save keystrokes later. But I
always I saw it, I was like, okay.
I should remember this, and I don't remember
how he did it.
Oh, there we go. It's container t container
t dot sock. So
Thank you. Okay. There
we go.
Cool.
We have Well,
we have what is speaker?
That's a metal l b. So we can
ignore the speaker part.
And STD was recreated thirty nine seconds ago.
And attempt one hundred and thirty five. So
the STD is yeah. It's rather unhappy.
Yeah. So
what's going on? Look at how do we
like look at this? I wanna see what
this container is.
Like, how do we we do, like, the
like a docker inspect on on this container?
So we can look at this I'm assuming
this Manifest. Wait. What? This is it all
here?
See, I we should have dumped the cluster
when we could have. This is this is
why he did this. I should have learned.
I should have been paying closer attention.
So we could just try, like, an STD
compact,
which would remove all the deleted items from
it and bring the size the database size
back into
hopefully, enough to get it started. Go
for it.
It's just compact, isn't it?
Yeah. Okay.
Number?
Oh, how do I pick a number?
Needs one argument?
Just do
Required revision has been compacted.
Can I let I have I have no
idea
no idea what you're doing? Me neither. So
let's try
the defrag command too.
I'm very natives. Let's try that. Yeah. Defrag's
fun. Let's do it. Let's do it.
Is there wait. Is there really an STD
cuddle defrag?
Is this Yes.
There is.
I'm buying a farm and moving. I'm buying
some goats. I'm so done with tech. I'm
done.
Alright. Well, that failed measurably.
Contacts deadline exceeded. That's a go error.
Yeah. So you should check out the alarms
as well.
That's a kind of a cool feature of
etcd cuddle.
And, yeah, and and the health.
Those are all really great things. Oh, yeah.
So there's the no space alarm.
Yeah.
So how can we list all of the
is there well, it would be like an
etsyv cuddle
d u
is what we wanna do?
Like, what's the etsyv cuddle, like, version of,
like, d u dash dash h?
Yeah. We're we're getting warmer.
Yeah.
I I I don't know. You're gonna have
to help me here. I I genuinely don't
know enough about etsyd. I can start to
Google
Etsy d
u or Etsy d cuddle.
Yeah. I'm not sure there's a d u.
If there is, I would love to learn
about it.
Yeah. I don't know. I this is just
what I think. Like, basically, I just I'm
assuming STD works like any database and it
just writes, you know, some sort of block
abstraction to regular old EXT four disk. And
I'm sure there's some way to browse and
explore those files and that's what I wanna
do. I whatever at CD and those those
guys have called exploring their proprietary
block abstraction,
let's find that and let's do that.
Well, it looks like we can get something
called a revision test key.
Sure.
So we have some people in chat talking
about disarming alarms and increasing size quota. Yeah.
I was googling how to increase the size,
but I haven't
and then I think
I'm I'm, like, literally, like, getting getting started
with a tt.i0
is where I am right now.
Yeah. Also, the my Twitch chat seems to
think that
SCD db size is limited
and time scale db.
Did you run out of disk space? No.
Tanya, while we're not out of disk space,
I'm talking to my my my Twitch
friends.
Yeah. I don't know. How do you
let's see. I'm I'll tell you guys what
I'm googling. STD, Cuddle,
size quota.
Alright. I found something under maintenance stop, so
we can get that a dash.
It's base quota. STD dash dash quota back
end bytes. What's that?
Well, that didn't work. We can't get the
current revision so that we could work out
how to delete the old revisions.
This
has a alarm disable.
I don't know if we can just do
that
just to keep it happy.
Lift,
disable,
disarm.
The alarm's gone. Does that mean SCD is
happy?
Try to get pods. That's our that's our
control. Right?
Okay. Get pods.
Alright. So we can just disable the alarm.
I don't know what that does with the
database quota though.
I don't know if it's gonna come back,
but I wonder if we can do the
revision command now
that I copy and paste it.
I'm just still gonna give us a yeah.
Still got a contact deadline.
SCD is probably not very happy.
Did Thomas, did you privilege escalate into something
with SCD cuddle, mutate SCD alarm size quota
something or other. This this isn't an app.
You didn't actually flush a bunch of frivolous
data to disk. You actually just told that
td to misbehave.
This is fine.
Well, the alarm's not coming back, and we
do have a working API server. So maybe
we can ignore it. Try to And delete
these honk pods?
Yeah. Delete the honk pods. I'm gonna well,
you you have the cursor right now, but
I I wanna dump the cluster config now
and look at the events in Kubernetes and
see what this guy's been doing. Alright. Okay.
We still can't write the STDs, so we
are gonna have to try and change the
database size.
Let's see. Etcd
cuddle
change database
size.
I don't like it when people mess with
entity, just for the record, Thomas.
Yeah.
So this is a learning opportunity.
So I'll I'll note that you you did
buy yourself about
ten seconds of runtime.
You've already squandered it. By turning Alright.
Yeah.
Let's see the CTL
database.
Yeah.
Everybody in my chat is like, we were
too nice when we broke our cluster.
No.
This is good.
So so I'm gonna give a an interesting
tidbit here. One of the fun things about
ETCD
is
that it's the way that it's set up,
it's listening on a public IP and port.
The
the etcd and the etcd server itself is
listening on a public IP that's that's reachable
if the the node is exposed and but
it's just it uses its own internal auth.
That's where all those the TLS, etcd search
management comes into play.
Correct.
So
are you saying that you are just flooding
well, like like I I don't know. I
I wanna start checking in to see how
etcd is actually mutating the file system and
seeing if you're truly filling
up our file system or at least or
if you're just filling up what etcd is
told is the limit for its file system.
So yeah. Try to set that right there.
Set that to something substantially larger.
That's huge.
I know. I I
Oh, because it's in a container.
Yeah.
Exec into the etcd container.
I don't know if we can do that
with cry control.
Here we can. Okay.
Exec IT, copy of the name of Yeah.
It's not there just now.
Oh, that's probably what's happening is the is
the container crashing and that explains the restarts
of the API server as well.
And
It's not coming back.
Look at the API server. Oh, we can't.
Come back at c d. Let me make
sure.
Yeah. It's not gonna work.
Wonder if oh, we can just add it
here.
Yeah.
Well, that should get restarted by the kubelet
and
Check the kubelet logs, journal cuddle f u
kubelet.
My favorite command to type.
Not sure if I see anything NCD ish
here.
Where did you edit the YTD pod manifest?
Yeah. And we oh, it's in a back
off state, so it may take a bit
longer to come back. Although, I think maybe
that's it.
There? And check can you check the alarms
again? I wanna see if that alarm came
back.
We can't speak to entity yet.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Because it's not ready.
Yeah. Wonder if that number was too big.
Maybe I'm making it worse.
That's six that's 16 megs. So change that
16 to
one zero two four.
Nope.
Get rid of that. There you go. That's
a gig.
Failed to delete.
So if you do
I guess, it'd be interesting to see what
CryCuddle is showing nowadays for
Yeah. Yeah.
So
Oh.
I mean, we can always just restart the
kubla and try and Yeah. Encourage it.
Yeah. Go for it. The only other questions
I have is whether like, I didn't realize
you could do shell expansion in the
YAML command
and the Kubectl command. I didn't realize it
went through a shell.
Is that in fact true?
Where did we do shell inspection? Did we
tilde when we should have homed?
Yeah. And here, where we passed the arguments
then. Yeah. That's not gonna work. Can you
actually do that?
I've never done it. So but
I I would be surprised if we can
run through bash.
That's a very good point.
Yeah. Just change that to
if it's in bytes,
There you go.
Alright.
And restart the cubelet again.
And can you list pods or containers? Docker
p s, Cryocuttle p s?
Yeah. We still can.
Or it's not attempted to start
at c d.
Kibble log What's
the Should be it notes not sync.
There it goes.
Let's see what
container d says.
Oh, it just came back up.
Yep.
There
it is. Yay.
Disarmed.
Well done.
And can you get pods
and delete those pods quickly quickly? Can you
delete all now?
Goddamn it.
Alright. I guess we're going bigger.
Alright.
Alright. Sorry for swearing on your I don't
I don't know the rules. This is, like,
corporate something.
I'm not allowed to swear like a sailor,
I don't think. People will get mad at
me. No. There is a code of conduct
which explicitly states you are allowed to swear,
but that's about all that's accepted.
Alright. Okay. I'm gonna give a hint that
the the pods are just a red herring.
So something else is filling up at city.
Yeah. If if you if you look at
the if you look at the pod manifest,
you'll see it's just a sleep eighty six
four hundred.
Okay.
Alright. So making that number bigger and restarting
the kubelet to restart it to d was
probably pointless because the thing is still running
on the system.
Alright. How do we find this road process
then?
Is it if
it's a road process that he put on
the system, I mean, we can start we
can start looking in the process tree. I
I wanted to look and intersect and see,
like, what has changed on the file system
in the last day, in the last two
days, the last three days.
Thomas is shaking his head no, though. Well,
I actually say no because he gave us
a hint. Alright? He said that this listens
on the public
thing. So let's
oh, no. Because it's gotta speak with other
nodes too.
How do we if you got something running
on your own machine that's talking to our
that's at c d.
Perhaps IP tables might help.
Perhaps IP tables. Yeah. List IP IP tables
cap l.
Let's just see what we have there. And,
like,
look.
You you may wanna see who all is
talking to etcd.
Tell Matt Tolpin
would at least tell us what all is
listening and
where it's listening.
So do we wanna tell Matt stat and
look for things on Port 2379?
Yeah.
Sure.
I Close.
What's what's like starting for next stat to
get more here?
Pulp in. I usually do pulp in, but
you can do whatever. Do you wanna type?
Because I'm not sure what flags you mean.
Alright. Okay.
Yeah.
So you
all those acts might be suspicious.
Right. So 157131124242
is an IP address we should maybe block.
Is that an IP address? Yes.
What? Yes. So he's he it looks like
he's doing something to add TD from wherever
this IP is,
which that looks like
it's a public IP. I don't recognize at
the top of my head.
Alright. So should we just add a drop
from that IP?
Sure. Go for it.
Alright. I'm gonna have to Google IP tables
now.
I was gonna say I was expecting I
wasn't expecting to see the hint in the
next step. I was expecting that you were
gonna have to look in TCP dump or
or something of that nature.
So you did mess with the network. Have
to solve that issue.
Okay.
So we'll just do
You can do a Four.
A s 20
four. That? No?
You can do a 30. Or yeah, that's
fine.
J drop.
And run the net stat again for me,
please.
Last act.
Should we restart etcd to would that flush
those connections?
Yeah. Go for it.
Did Thomas, did you grab the go
ahead.
I was gonna say I just noticed in
another window that
something that I had been observing has changed
state
in that I can no longer connect to
it no it can no longer connect to
etcd. So
I see. You did put something outside of
the cluster.
So oh, okay. I was polite. I put
in a teammate backdoor in that container
that I could at least host exec through,
but I didn't like, I'm not running anything
on any of my local boxes. That's just
not nice.
I thought this was easy, but Thomas, come
on. Yeah. It
just a very simple denial of service attack.
That's it. Alright.
Did you h But now you still you
still have to
so I can know you know, it's no
longer mutating anything. So
Sure. So whatever it was mutated.
Yeah. Alright. So we have h t d
endpoint
health.
There's no response He
he dossed etcd on the public port on
our cluster, which was preventing us from
scheduling work in our cluster because that CD
was filling up.
So I think let's let's try to tidy
up at CD. Let's get the API server
healthy
and let's
I like, I mean, obviously, I wanna start
looking at other
networking rules in this infrastructure, but we can
talk about that later after breakfast. I will
say you have you have solved the the
the main, like, root cause here. Although, you
still have to clean up after it.
Right.
The whole pods are are gone or at
least they're going. So that's a star.
Well done.
Was there anything else on this system that
we
Can you list containers really quick for me?
Okay.
Thank you.
And try to run your deployment, yeah, one
more time.
Sorry. I'm just barking commands at you. I
apologize. Oh, no. Please, the
let's make sure.
Yeah. I think
Yeah. It's happy.
So the the key here was actually you
increasing the the space for ETCD
Mhmm. And combined with the lack
of
my scripts to DOS the
the data.
So can I just confirm them? Right?
That is how STD
works
Right. On a Kubernetes cluster. Like, so anyone
could do that to any public STD that
they found. You no. You you have to
have the certs. Alright. Okay. So I'm just
actually That's
what I was worried about. Okay. So Yeah.
So
the the
the takeaway here, just kinda play it back,
you
scheduled a pod, you grabbed the STD certs
from the system because I mean, we we
had root. Once you had the certs, you
then effectively I mean, etcd cuddle is a
well known tool. So you used etcd cuddle
to hit what you knew was a publicly
listening TCP port.
And from there, you had the keys to
etcd and you just decided to pick on
etcd for us.
Yep. Just just flooding etcd with rights.
Lovely.
Okay. So let's can I can I can
we just check a few things here? I'm
just curious why why we're here. This is
a great learning opportunity.
Can you go back to that where that
main directory where those those dot w files,
whatever they were, the etcd rights?
Yeah. The far left
etcd Yeah. And the right head log. So
oh, member.
There
you go. And can we just see how
big these are now? I'm just curious how
how much of the etcd of these rights
are being persisted,
and how much of them are still there?
Etcd by default will at least
as as configured here, will only allow 2.1
gigs of data to be stored.
Yeah.
It's pretty trivial to flood that.
Interesting. This is a great exploit. Good job.
I did not realize ETCD was this
subject to to flooding. But again, like the
certs is this is a really good one.
Yeah. I was I was going with TLS
flooding instead, but it seems like etcd is
no longer it's no longer an issue for
etcd to
to
a lot of the DOS attacks I had
considered were no longer worked.
I see. I I remember hearing
some some HP floods
on a couple of the Kubernetes components back
in the day, but I haven't actually seen
I haven't seen anything like this. So I'm
just like, can you just share a little
bit about your flood? Just, like, you don't
I don't have to see it, but I'm
just curious. Were you just able to write,
like, a megabyte of data and just flood
that in a loop or something?
Yeah. That's basically
so at etcd cuddle has a put command,
and you can put random keys.
In fact, you can actually just keep putting
to the same key, and an an etcd
will store each revision. So it's a d
d of dev random
into the etcd cuddle. And so Oh. You
can piped you piped dev random to etcd
cuddle?
Yeah. So you can use the so we
talked about compact and defrag, and we showed
those off late earlier.
And had it only been writing to the
same key, that could have helped. But
I decided in the end actually just to
write to random key names as well, and
it was no longer helpful.
Interesting.
Awesome. Great. I've I've learned awful lot from
both of you today. So
thank you very much for joining me. I
don't think we have time to give you
my cluster,
so
I'll maybe open it up to people on
Twitter or something. I don't know yet.
Because we've already done it over time. I
won't I won't keep you any longer. But
thank you both for joining me. There's lots
of knowledge here shared and I appreciate that.
And I hope you both have a wonderful
day.
Any last words?
Thomas, I'd love to catch up after this
and, like, nice to meet both of you
face to face. But, yeah, this has been
so much fun. Thanks for inviting me. This
was I had so much fun with this.
This was really good for me. My therapist
agrees. This is this is good for me.
Yeah. Same. I I learned a lot just
from, you know, not only building the case,
but seeing seeing the case solved. So
and as well from
your your evil. That that could have been
really brutal.
I I so I'm glad I I kept
it where I did, and I left I
left, like, a good a good set of
breadcrumbs for you. Yeah.
I I will do a write up on
mine, and I'll probably do a write up
on yours as well on my blog after
all this.
Sounds good.
Awesome. I'll send you the commands.
Alright. Well, thank you both again. Have a
great day, and I'll speak to you soon.
Bye.